harrah's et 350 km de talus sur les 370
quoi alors vous voyez un peu les dégâts
depuis 1950 70% des zones bocagères ont
disparu en cause le remembrement des
terres agricoles menées par l'état
jusqu'aux années soixante dix une
catastrophe pour la biodiversité en 2021
le gouvernement a décidé de consacrer 50
millions d'euros à la restauration des
bocages son objectif replanter 7000 km
de haies et d'arbres d'ici la fin 2022
car autrefois rck la campagne française
ressembler à ça marcel petit exigu d'où
perte de surfaces cultivables parcelles
dispersées souvent un code d'accès d'où
perte de temps tout change à la fin de
la guerre l'agriculture doit se
moderniser
les paysans sont obligés de cultiver des
surfaces plus grandes pour augmenter
leur rendement
le cadastre et refondu
les parcelles groupé est redistribué
champ plus vaste mieux dessiner plus
accessible gain de temps de qualité de
surface
la campagne se transforme en gigantesque
chantier ingénieurs géomètres ouvriers
pelleteuse et bulldozer remodèle le
bocage ancestrales il y a donc dans le
cadre du remembrement
premièrement l'arrachage des la rasage
des talus et ceci est subventionné à 80
% par le ministère de l'agriculture des
chemins d'accès et des fossés
d'assainissement remplacent les haies et
des limites des champs lunaire
l'écosystème c'est modifie rapidement il
y a les conséquences très important de
tous ordres il s'agit d'abord de l'eau
du régime d autres qui est contrarié il
s'agit de l'érosion par les évents
érosion du sol dont nous avons déjà
constaté les effets côté culture le
bilan est sombre
tu es jour où on les détruit qui a une
évapotranspiration qui était et qui
diminue forcément la quantité et la
qualité des cultures
victime collatérale de la disparition
des talus brise-vent le bétail on a
moins les bains ya du vent face aux
alertes répétées le gouvernement change
de braquet
il propose de modifier des techniques de
remembrement mais c'est déjà trop tard
je considère qu'il faut ne pas tout
raser car le bocage répondait à une
nécessité d' équilibre biologique la fin
du remembrement en 1975 ne stoppera pas
la disparition des est grignotée par
l'expansion céréalière érosion des sols
baisse des récoltes disparition de la
biodiversité
autant de conséquences avérées
aujourd'hui
[Musique]